all right this is a fascinating story
about how backwards the american right
wing currently is i know many of you
have been following the controversy with
podcast host joe rogan i've been on the
rogan program two times i've also spent
the last year calling out lots of the
misinformation that has been divulged on
the joe rogan program initially the
controversy with joe rogan was over
coveted disinformation including
multiple guests making outrageous claims
about vaccines and covid which i
couldn't possibly list now but it led to
numerous musical artists including neil
young and joni mitchell and others to
pull their music from spotify and it led
to joe rogan putting out a statement
about the coveted misinformation saying
i'm not trying to spread disinformation
i'm not trying to be controversial
and i'm going to make an effort to have
more people on with what we might
consider sort of like the mainline
medical science views and some people
felt the apology was forced some people
felt the apollo apology was disingenuous
some people liked it etc shortly after
the covet disinformation controversy a
compilation video of rogan using the
n-word on his show from the last decade
plus came out and it was a whole new
controversy including the artist india
ari
saying i'm pulling my music from spotify
and rogan doing another apology video
saying listen when i watch this stuff
um it's it's not good i recognize it's
not good and
i didn't have racist intent and okay he
did another apology some people didn't
like the apology some people liked the
apology others said this is the right
thing to say other said this is the
wrong thing to say the content of it is
not actually at issue here
what is fascinating is that the right is
now turning on rogan
because he apologized because he
apologized early on in this controversy
the right were the defenders of rogan
saying it's great that he's putting out
their alternative views about coveting
vaccines even if they're completely not
based in fact uh this is a guy who you
know the don't cancel the the race the
use of the n-word is fine it's all fine
rogan's great great great take 100
million bucks to come to rumble we
learned yesterday all this different
stuff
but now that rogan has apologized
and i'll be honest i think the apologies
are sincere it doesn't mean anything in
particular about rogan's intent when he
said this stuff i have no idea but i do
think his apologies are sincere at least
as far as he feels today now the right
is turning on rogan
first and foremost donald trump putting
out a statement saying joe rogan is an
interesting and popular guy
but he's got to stop apologizing to the
fake news and radical left maniacs and
lunatics how many ways can you say
you're sorry joe just go about what you
do so well and don't let them make you
look weak and frightened that's not you
and it never will be so trump not
pleased with the apologies but still
sort of deferential to rogan but then
all sorts of conservative media and
elected officials
saying rogan is wrong to apologize let's
look first at a clip of florida governor
ron desantis saying no no no the apology
is bad mob will come after people and
they're targeting rogan because he's
threatening to upset the apple cart on
some of the things that they're holding
dear and with covet he's just bringing
opposing views he's letting people
decide they say he's against vacs i've
not listened to a show but then i read
he specifically advocated for people
with comorbidities and elderly to get
vaccinated and so a lot of this is just
i think he's got a huge audience uh i
think a lot of the legacy outlets and i
think the left fear the fact that he can
reach so many people and so they're out
to destroy him but now the funny thing
is rogan's audience by most estimates is
down 50 since he moved to spotify so
this fear about the audience is kind of
a weird thing but okay desantis says the
apology was wrong and trump says the
apology was wrong but then
look at what is happening on other
conservative media outlets here is
stephen crowder weighing in on the
apology stuff um
i'm not going to lie i'm i i was upset
yes i was angry with no with joe as well
uh
and i'll explain to you why i'm more
angry of course with the people who've
tried to yeah i hate to use the term
canceled culture but the people who have
tried to destroy his life and his
livelihood now joe rogan is bigger than
them so good for him it shouldn't affect
him i hope he understands the power that
he has unfortunately he's caved a little
bit and i just
it that makes it harder for everybody
else and i have a lot of respect for joe
i think he's a good guy i've spent some
time with him i just so it's always hard
for me just full disclosure to be
objective when i know somebody so anyway
there's stephen crowder stephen crowder
says joe rogan caved
then we go next to steve bannon trump
propagandist steve bannon also not
pleased
let's listen to him
okay welcome you're in the war room it's
monday 7 february the year overlord 2022
now with closing in
almost 140
million um
downloads on the podcast and i just want
to add we did that without uh spotify
and we did that without groveling to
spotify uh oh more on spotify in the
weeks days and weeks ahead
but it is uh it is amazing
uh and no to joe rogan the more you
grovel
the more episodes they're going to take
down the more so joe rogan being
admonished by steve bannon for groveling
and then we also have glenn beck glenn
beck doesn't like
what rogan has done
and i think the audio comes in
him first of all joe
never apologize and i don't mean it
like never apologize when you've done
something that you find
offensive or wrong
you should always apologize when you
uh have done something that you're
ashamed of so apology accepted apology
uh warranted perhaps perhaps maybe i if
you were using it in context i don't
think so but maybe should joe biden
apologize for what he said in that in
that i
i don't know every word that joe rogan
has said on the podcast so maybe he has
thrown it out there you know 12 years
ago
without context you know what i mean i i
don't know so i'm giving him the benefit
of the doubt and saying
you know if that was what happened
then you should apologize but not to
these people not to these people
if you really did hurt and offend people
with it
your audience would have told you that
you wouldn't be as successful as you are
now this is just it's just kind of weird
it's a weird argument that glenn beck
makes because
he wasn't as well known at the time that
he
did the segments that became part of
that compilation so i don't you know the
question i the better question would be
if you said that stuff now
what would be the reaction from your
much bigger audience and i think it's
very clear that much of the current
audience would be offended so anyway the
point here is what has gotten the right
to now say joe you're groveling joe
you're doing the wrong thing
is that he has apologized an apology
that i know many in my audience think is
completely insincere you know i've i've
said this idea that that that an apology
is not warranted here
um seems bizarre to me
and of course if you believe that he was
forced by spotify to apologize in order
to keep his show that would be a reason
to think the apology is disingenuous uh
but it doesn't appear to be the case
spotify has said we're keeping rogan
we've pulled some episodes because of
some of the content but we like rogan
we're keeping broken and um it is
amazing how what has triggered the right
is you know a dozen uses of the n-word
no they're fine with that
total out and out coveted disinformation
from guests that rogan doesn't challenge
they say no he's giving alternate views
that's that's totally fine the apology
has catalyzed and coalesced trump
desantis stephen crowder stephen bannon
glenn beck and others who i'm not
playing today to say now rogan is doing
the wrong thing the apology is now
the wrong thing these people are truly
incredible and it just reminds us these
are not good uh counterparts to any kind
of real discussions
about solving problems
on the planet that affect humans
and moving forward in a productive way
they're just not good faith actors
one of our sponsors is kamikoto who
creates elegant high-end japanese steel
kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan
i'm a huge fan of japanese kitchen
knives i've owned a bunch of different
sets none as nice as my kamikoto knives
made with real japanese steel every
knife comes in a beautiful heavy duty
ash wood box and a lifetime guarantee
you can get them in several different
sets and combinations kamikoto makes it
really easy to figure out which one is
best for you you can also pick up one of
kamikodo's sharpening wet stones which
are designed especially for kamikodo
knives i've had an excellent experience
using kamikodo knives in my kitchen at
home it just feels comfortable in your
hand the mechanics of slicing with high
quality japanese knives like these feel
really really nice and right now
kamikoto is having a huge valentine's
day sale
you get 50 off on top of their other
offers when you go to kamikodo.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below